Esta espléndida pieza, la música de apertura,
¨La marcha de los elefantes¨ de Aida, es la música que he escogido para mi funeral.
(Risas)
Y pueden ver porqué. Es triunfalista.
Sentiría -- No sentiré nada, pero si pudiera,
me sentiría triunfante por el solo hecho de haber vivido,
y haber vivido en este espléndido planeta,
y por haber tenido la oportunidad de entender
algo del porqué estaba aquí, para empezar, sin haber existido antes.
¿Pueden entender mi peculiar acento inglés?
Como el resto de ustedes, ayer estuve hipnotizado durante la sesión de fauna.
Robert Full, Frans Lanting y otros...
la belleza de las cosas que nos mostraron.
Lo único ligeramente irritante fue cuando Jeffrey Katzenberg habló sobre el mustang (caballo salvaje).
«Las criaturas más esplendidas que Dios puso sobre la faz de la tierra».
Ahora, por supuesto, sabemos que no era exactamente lo que él quiso decir...
pero en este país en estos momentos, no se puede ser demasiado cauteloso
(Risas)
Soy un biólogo, y el teorema central de nuestra materia: la teoría del diseño,
la teoría de Darwin de la evolución por selección natural.
En el ámbito profesional en cualquier lugar es, por supuesto, universalmente aceptada.
En ámbitos no profesionales fuera de Estados Unidos, es ampliamente ignorada.
Pero en ámbitos no profesionales dentro de Estados Unidos
provoca tanta hostilidad -
(Risas)
- que sería justo decir que los biólogos estadunidenses se encuentran en estado de guerra.
La guerra es tan preocupante en el presente,
originando demandas en una Estado tras otro,
que sentí que tenía que decir algo al respecto.
Si quieren saber lo que yo tengo que decir acerca del darwinismo,
me temo que vais a tener que leer mis libros,
que no encontrarán en la librería de afuera.
(Risas)
Juicios recientes...
a menudo incorporan una supuesta nueva versión del creacionismo.
llamada diseño inteligente o DI.
No se dejen engañar. No hay nada nuevo con respecto al DI.
Es simplemente creacionismo bajo otro nombre.
Rebautizado -- elegí esta palabra deliberadamente --
(Risas)
por razones tácticas y políticas.
Los argumentos de los presuntos teóricos del DI
son los mismos viejos argumentos que han sido refutados una y otra vez,
desde Darwin hasta el presente.
Hay un efectivo grupo de presión por la evolución
coordinando la lucha en nombre de la ciencia,
y trato de hacer todo lo que puedo para ayudarlos,
pero les molesta mucho cuando personas como yo se atreven a mencionar..
..que da la casualidad que somos ateos a la vez que evolucionistas.
Consideran que estamos creando problemas, y pueden entender porqué.
Ya que los creacionistas carecen de todo argumento científico coherente para su causa
..recurren a la fobia popular en contra del ateísmo,
«enseñen evolución a sus hijos en la clase de biología
y ellos pronto caerán en la drogadicción, hurto mayor y perversión sexual».
(Risas)
De hecho, por supuesto, teólogos con formación académica, desde el Papa hacia abajo
apoyan firmemente la teoría de evolución.
Este libro: "Encontrando el Dios de Darwin", de Kenneth Miller,
es uno de los ataques más eficaces al Diseño Inteligente
que conozco, y es así de efectivo..
..porque está escrito por un cristiano devoto.
Gente como Kenneth Miller podrían ser llamados "mensajeros de Dios" para el grupo de presión de la evolución.
(Risas)
porque exponen la mentira de que el evolucionismo es, de hecho,
equivalente a ateísmo.
Personas como yo, por otra parte, crean problemas.
Pero aquí, quiero decir algo bueno con respecto a los creacionistas.
No es algo que haga a menudo, así que escuchen con atención.
(Risas)
Pienso que tienen razón en una cosa.
Pienso que tienen razón al pensar que la evolución
es fundamentalmente hostil hacia religión.
Ya he dicho que muchos individuos evolucionistas, como el Papa,
son también religiosos, pero creo que se engañan a si mismos.
Creo que un verdadero entendimiento del darwinismo
es profundamente corrosivo a la fe religiosa.
Ahora, podría sonar como si yo fuera a predicar ateísmo,
Y les quiero asegurar que no es eso lo que haré.
Con una audiencia tan sofisticada como esa -como esta-
sería como darle una misa al Papa.
No, a lo que quiero incitarles,
(Risas)
en lugar de eso a lo que les quiero persuadir es al ateísmo militante.
(Aplausos)
Pero eso es ponerlo muy negativamente.
Si yo quisiera, si yo fuera una persona que estuviera interesada en preservar la fe religiosa,
tendría mucho miedo del poder positivo de las ciencias evolutivas,
y en general de cualquier ciencia, pero en particular de la evolución..
..por inspirar y cautivar, precisamente porque es atea.
Ahora, el problema para cualquier teoría de diseño biológico
es explicar la gran improbabilidad estadística de los seres vivos.
Improbabilidad estadística en el sentido de un buen diseño
(complejidad es otra palabra para eso).
El argumento creacionista estándar -sólo hay uno, todos se reducen a éste-
parte de la improbabilidad estadística:
«Los seres vivos son demasido complejos para existir por casualidad,
por tanto debieron haber tenido un diseñador.
Por supuesto, este argumento se dispara a si mismo en el pie,
cualquier diseñador capaz de diseñar algo verdaderamente complejo..
tiene que ser mucho más complejo en si mismo, y eso es antes de que empecemos a
considerar las otras cosas que se espera que él haga,
como perdonar pecados, bendecir bodas, escuchar oraciones,
apoyar nuestro lado en una guerra,
(Risas)
desaprobar nuestras vidas sexuales y demás.
La complejidad es el problema que cualquier teoría biologica tiene que resolver,
y no se puede resolver postulando un agente que es aún más complejo,
y agravando aún mas el problema.
La selección natural darwiniana es tan pasmosamente elegante
porque resuelve el problema de explicar la complejidad
en términos ni más ni menos que de simplicidad.
En esencia, lo hace brindando una suave rampa
de incremento gradual paso a paso.
Pero aquí, sólo quiero dejar claro que
la elegancia del darwinismo es corrosiva a la religión
precisamente por ser tan elegante, tan sencilla, tan poderosa,
tan económicamente poderosa.
Tiene la vigorosa economía de un hermoso puente colgante.
La teoría de Dios, no es sólo una mala teoría,
resulta ser, en principio, incapaz de realizar lo que se espera de ella.
Bueno, regresando a las tácticas y al grupo de presión evolucionista
quiero discutir que crear problemas podría ser precisamente la acción correcta.
Mi táctica de ataque al creacionismo es diferente a la del grupo de presión evolucionista.
Mi táctica al atacar al creacionismo es atacar a la religión en su totalidad
y en este punto necesito reconocer el extraordinario tabú
que existe en contra de criticar a la religión
y lo haré en las palabras del fallecido Douglas Adams
un querido amigo que, si nunca fue invitado a TED,
ciertamente debería haberlo sido.
(Richard Saul Wurman: «Lo fue».)
Richard Dawkins: ¡Lo fue! Bueno, eso pensé.
Él empezó su discurso, el cual fue grabado en Cambridge
poco antes de morir.
Empieza diciendo como la ciencia funciona mediante la verificación de hipótesis..
las cuales son vulnerables a ser refutadas, y prosigue diciendo,
y cito: « la religión no parece funcionar así.
Cuenta con ciertas ideas centrales a las cuales nos referimos como sagradas o santas,
lo que significa que esta es una idea o noción
de la cual no tienes derecho a hablar mal.
Simplemente, no puedes, ¿por qué no? ¡Porque no!
(Risas)
¿Por qué será que es perfectamente legítimo apoyar republicanos o demócratas,
un modelo económico en contra de otro, Macintosh en lugar de Windows...?
pero tener una opinión sobre el origen del universo,
acerca de quien creó el universo, ¡no! ¡Eso es sagrado!
Así que estamos acostumbrados a no desafiar las ideas religiosas
y es muy interesante cuánta furia crea Richard
cuando lo hace.» (Se refería a mí, no a él).
"Todo mundo se pone frenético con eso,
porque no tienes permiso de decir esas cosas. Aunque sí lo miras racionalmente,
no hay razón por la que esas ideas no deberían estar abiertas a debate
como cualquier otra, excepto que de alguna manera hemos acordado
que no deben estarlo», y éste es el fin de la cita de Douglas.
Desde mi punto de vista, no sólo la ciencia es corrosiva para la religión,
sino la religión es corrosiva para la ciencia.
Enseña a las personas a estar satisfechas con triviales y supernaturales 'explicaciones'
y les ciega a las maravillosas y verdaderas explicaciones que tenemos a nuestro alcance.
Les enseña a aceptar la autoridad, la revelación y la fe,
en lugar de a insistir siempre en la evidencia.
Ese es Douglas Adams, fotografía magnífica de su libro, "Mañana no estarán".
Ahora, existe una típica revista científica, "The Quarterly Review of Biology",
y estoy armando, como editor invitado
una edición especial sobre la pregunta, ¿mató un asteroide a los dinosaurios?
Y el primer artículo es un artículo científico estándar
mostrando evidencia: «Capa de iridio en los límites del Cretácico-terciario
y cráter en Yucatán datado con potasio-argón
indican que 'un asteroide mató a los dinosaurios'».
Un artículo científico totalmente ordinario.
Ahora, el que sigue, "Al Presidente de la Real Sociedad
le ha sido revelada una fuerte convicción interna: (Risas)
que 'un asteroide mató a los dinosaurios'".
(Risas)
Se le ha revelado privadamente al profesor Huxdane
que 'un asteroide mató a los dinosaurios'.
(Risas)
¨El profesor Hordley fue instruido
en tener una creencia absoluta e incuestionable en
(Risas)
que 'un asteroide mató a los dinosaurios'”.
El profesor Hawkins ha promulgado un dogma oficial
que compromete a todos los "hawkinsianos" leales
de que 'un asteroide mató a los dinosaurios'.
(Risas)
¡Por supuesto, eso es inconcebible!
Pero supongan...
(Aplausos)
-en 1987, un reportero le pregunto George Bush, padre,
si él reconocía la misma ciudadanía y patriotismo
de los estadounidenses que son ateos.
La respuesta del Sr. Bush se ha vuelto tristemente célebre:
«No, no sé si los ateos deberían ser considerados ciudadanos,
o si deberían ser considerados patriotas.
Esta es una nación bajo Dios».
La intolerancia de Bush no fue un error aislado,
no habló de más en el calor del momento, para luego retractarse.
Él mantuvo su opinión frente a repetidas peticiones de clarificación o de que se retractara.
Lo dijo en serio.
Es más, él sabía que esta postura no amenazaba su elección, todo lo contrario.
Tanto demócratas como republicanos exhiben su religiosidad
si quieren ser electos. Los dos partidos evocan: «una nación bajo Dios».
¡Qué diría Thomas Jefferson!
Incidentalmente, no me siento orgulloso de ser británico con frecuencia,
pero no puedes evitar hacer la comparación.
(Aplausos)
En la práctica, ¿qué es un ateo?
Un ateo es sólo alguien que siente por "Yahveh"
lo mismo que cualquier cristiano decente siente sobre Thor o Baal o el Becerro de oro.
Como ya se ha dicho antes, todos somos ateos de la mayoría de dioses
en los que humanidad ha creído. Algunos sólo vamos un dios más allá.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Y de cualquier forma que definamos "ateísmo", éste es sin lugar a dudas el tipo de creencia académica
que una persona tiene derecho a tener sin ser estigmatizado
como un "no patriota" o "no ciudadano" sin pode presentarse a unas elecciones.
No obstante, es un hecho innegable que el declararse uno mismo como ateo
es equivalente a presentarse como Hitler o Belzebub.
Y todo eso proviene de la percepción de que los ateos
son una minoría extraña que está en decadencia.
Natalie Angier escribió un artículo más bien triste en el New Yorker,
describiendo lo sola se sentía como atea.
Es claro que ella se siente en una minoría asediada,
sin embargo, ¿cuan adelantados están numéricamente los estadounidenses ateos?
El último sondeo resulta ser una lectura sorprendentemente alentadora.
Los cristianos, por supuesto, ocupan una enorme tajada
de la población, con casi 160 millones.
¿Pero cuál pensarían que es el segundo grupo más grande,
rebasando por mayoría a los judíos con 2.8 millones, musulmanes con 1.1 millones
e hindús, budistas y otras religiones juntas?
El segundo grupo mayoritario, con casi 30 millones,
es el descrito como no religioso o secular.
No puedes dejar de preguntarte por qué los políticos en busca de votos
son intimidados proverbialmente por el poder, por ejemplo, del grupo de presión judío.
El estado de Israel parece deber toda su existencia
al voto judío-estadounidense, y al mismo tiempo
consignando a los no religiosos al olvido político.
El voto secular no religioso, si es debidamente movilizado,
es nueve veces más grande que el electorado judío.
¿Por qué ésta minoría mucho más importante
no toma la iniciativa para ejercer su poder político?
Bueno, esto sobre la cantidad. ¿Qué hay de calidad?
¿Existe alguna correlación, positiva o negativa,
entre la inteligencia y la tendencia a ser religioso?
(Risas)
La encuesta que cité, la encuesta de identificación religiosa estadounidense,
no desglosó los datos con respecto al nivel socioeconómico o al educativo,
coeficiente intelectual u otros.
Pero un articulo reciente de Paul G. Bell de la revista Mensa
nos provee de algunas señales en el horizonte.
Mensa, como ustedes saben, es una organización mundial
para personas con un coeficiente intelectual muy alto.
Y de un meta-análisis de la literatura,
Bell concluye que, cito: “De 43 investigaciones realizadas desde 1927
sobre la relación entre creencias religiosas e inteligencia o nivel educativo,
todas menos cuatro encontraron una conexión inversa.
Esto es, cuanto más alto el nivel de inteligencia o educativo,
más baja la probabilidad de ser religioso".
Bueno, no he visto los 42 estudios originales y no puedo comentar sobre dicho meta-análisis
pero me gustaría ver más investigaciones en este sentido.
Y sé que hay, si pudiera hacer una pequeña publicidad,
hay personas en esta audiencia
fácilmente capaces de financiar una encuesta masiva de investigación para resolver esta incógnita,
y les sugiero que así sea, ya que valdría la pena.
Pero dejen que les muestre ahora algunos datos
que han sido apropiadamente publicados y analizados
sobre un grupo en especial, a saber, los científicos de primer nivel.
En 1998, Larson y Witham
encuestaron a la crema de los científicos estadounidenses,
aquellos que habían sido elegidos como los mejores en la Academia Nacional de Ciencias,
y dentro de este grupo
la creencia en un dios personal cayó drásticamente a un 7%.
Alrededor de un 20% son agnósticos, y el resto de ellos podrían ser directamente denominados ateos.
Resultados similares se encontraron con respecto a la creencia en la inmortalidad personal.
Entre científicos biólogos, las cifras son aún más bajas,
sólo un 5,5 por ciento cree en dios. Científicos físicos: 7.5 por ciento.
No he visto datos correspondientes para la élite de eruditos
en otros campos, como historia o filosofía,
pero estaría sorprendido si los resultados fueran diferentes.
Por tanto, hemos llegado a una situación verdaderamente notable,
una discordancia grotesca entre los intelectuales estadounidenses
y el electorado estadounidense.
Una opinión filosófica sobre la naturaleza del universo
la cual es compartida por la gran mayoría de los mejores científicos estadounidenses
y probablemente por la mayoría de los intelectuales en general,
es tan repugnante para el electorado estadounidense
que no hay candidato en elecciones populares que se atreva a afirmar eso en público.
Si estoy en lo correcto, esto significa que los altos cargos
en el mas poderoso país del mundo
está negada a quienes son precisamente más calificados, los intelectuales,
a menos que estén preparados para mentir sobre sus creencias.
En pocas palabras, las oportunidades políticas estadunidenses
están fuertemente en contra de aquellos
que son simultáneamente inteligentes y honestos.
(Aplausos)
No soy ciudadano de este país, así que espero que no piensen que es inapropiado,
si sugiero que algo tiene que hacerse al respecto.
(Risas)
Y ya he dado algunas pistas sobre qué es ese algo.
Por lo que he visto de TED, pienso que este puede ser el lugar ideal para iniciar esto,
De nuevo, me temo que costará dinero.
Necesitamos una concienciadora
campaña para que los ateos estadounidenses salgan del armario.
(Risas)
Esta podría ser una campaña similar a la organizada por homosexuales
hace algunos años,
aunque, dios no lo permita, que nos rebajemos
a forzar a gente a manifestarse en público.
En la mayoría de los casos, la gente que se manifieste
ayudará a destruir el mito de que está mal ser ateo.
Por lo contrario,
ayudarán a demostrar que los ateos son frecuentemente el tipo de personas
que podrían servir de modelos decentes a seguir para tus hijos.
El tipo de gente que un publicista podría usar para recomendar un producto,
El tipo de gente que está sentada en este auditorio.
Debería haber un efecto de bola de nieve, de retroalimentación positiva,
de forma que cuantos más nombres tenemos, más obtendremos.
Podría haber no linealidades, efectos de umbral.
Una vez obtenida una masa crítica,
hay una aceleración abrupta en el reclutamiento.
Y de nuevo, esto requerirá dinero.
Sospecho que la palabra «ateo» en si
contiene o permanece como un obstáculo
desproporcionado a su auténtico significado, y es un enorme obstáculo para personas
que de otra manera estarían felices de darse a conocer como ateas.
Consecuentemente, ¿qué otras palabras podrían ser usadas para facilitar este camino,
engrasar los engranajes, endulzar la píldora? El mismo Darwin prefería «agnóstico»,
y no sólo en lealtad a su amigo Huxley quien creó el término.
Darwin dijo: «Nunca he sido un ateo
en el mismo sentido de negar la existencia de Dios,
Pienso que en general, "agnóstico"
sería las descripción más correcta de mi estado mental».
Se volvió, incluso, inusualmente irritado con Edward Aveling.
Aveling era un ateo militante
quien fracasó al tratar de persuadir a Darwin
de aceptar la dedicatoria de su libro sobre ateísmo,
incidentalmente, originando el mito fascinante
de que Karl Marx trató de dedicar "El capital" a Darwin,
lo que no hizo. Realmente fue Edward Aveling.
Lo que pasó fue que la amante de Aveling era la hija de Marx.
Y cuando ambos, Darwin y Marx, murieron,
los documentos de Darwin y Aveling se traspapelaron
y una carta de Darwin decía:”Mi estimado señor: Muchas gracias,
pero no quiero que me dedique su libro”,
fue erróneamente interpretada como dirigida a Marx
originando todo este mito del cual probablemente han escuchado antes.
Es como un mito urbano
que Marx trató de dedicar ¨El capital¨ a Darwin.
De todas formas, fue Aveling y cuando se conocieron, Darwin reto a Aveling:
“¿Por qué se hacen llamar 'ateos'?
"Agnóstico", replicó Aveling, "sólo era ateo dicho respetablemente,
y ateo sólo era agnóstico dicho agresivamente".
Darwin se quejó, “¿por qué tienes que ser tan agresivo?”
Darwin pensaba que el ateísmo estaba muy bien para los intelectuales
pero que la gente ordinaria no estaba, cito, “madura para esto”.
Lo cual es claro, nuestro viejo y conocido argumento de "no crear problemas".
No está documentado si Aveling le dijo a Darwin que bajara sus humos.
(Risas)
Pero de todas formas, eso fue hace más de 100 años.
Pesarían que hemos crecido desde entonces.
Un amigo, un judío inteligente no practicante,
quien incidentemente guardó el sabbat
por razones de solidaridad cultural,
se describe a si mismo como un "agnóstico del ratoncito Pérez".
Él no se llamaría ateo,
porque es, en principio, imposible de probar lo opuesto,
pero agnóstico por si solo podría sugerir que la existencia de dios
tiene por tanto la misma probabilidad como la de su inexistencia.
Así que mi amigo es estrictamente agnóstico del ratoncito Pérez,
pero esto no es muy probable, ¿o sí?.. como Dios.
De allí la frase: "agnóstico del ratonito Pérez",
pero Bertrand Russell señaló el mismo punto
usando una hipotética tetera en órbita alrededor de Marte.
Tendríamos que ser estrictamente agnósticos
sobre la existencia, o no, de una tetera en órbita alrededor de Marte.
Pero eso no significa que se considere la probabilidad de su existencia
mano a mano con la de su inexistencia.
La lista de cosas de las cuales deberíamos ser estrictamente agnósticos
no termina con la leyenda del ratoncito Pérez y teteras. Esta es infinita,
si quieres creer una de ellas en particular:
unicornios, ratones de dientes o teteras o Yahveh,
la obligación es tuya de probar por qué.
La obligación de probar el porqué no creemos no es del resto de nosotros.
Nosotros, los que somos ateos, también somos «a-ratonistas» y «a-teteristas ».
(Risas)
Pero no nos preocupamos en decirlo,
y ésta es la razón por la que mi amigo usó la leyenda del ratoncito Pérez dientes
como una etiqueta de aquello a lo que la mayoría de la gente llamaría "ateo".
De cualquier forma, si queremos incitar profundamente a los ateos a que se manifiesten en público,
vamos a tener que encontrar algo mejor
que agnóstico en ratones de dientes o agnóstico de teteras en nuestras pancartas.
¿Qué tal «humanistas»?
Esta palabra tiene la ventaja de una red mundial, de asociaciones muy bien organizadas
y revistas y demás ya en existencia.
Mi único problema con esto es su aparente antropocentrismo.
Una de las cosas que aprendimos de Darwin
es que la especie humana es sólo una
entre millones de primas, algunas cercanas, algunas distantes.
Y existen otras posibilidades, como ¨naturista¨,
pero también tiene problemas de confusión
porque Darwin habría pensado ¨naturalista¨-
”naturalista” significa, por supuesto, lo opuesto a sobrenatural-
y así se usa algunas veces.
Darwin se habría confundido con el otro significado de naturalista,
el que el, por supuesto, y supongo que habrá otros
que lo confundirían con nudismo.
(Risas)
Estas personas podrían ser pertenecientes a la turba de linchadores británicos
que el año pasado atacaron a un pediatra que confundieron con un pedófilo.
(Risas)
Pienso que la mejor de las alternativas disponibles para ateo es simplemente ¨no-teista¨.
Carece de la fuerte connotación de que definitivamente no hay un dios,
y podría ser fácilmente aceptada por agnósticos de tetera o leyendas de ratones de dientes.
Es completamente compatible con el Dios de los físicos.
Cuando gente como -- cuando ateos
como Stephen Hawking and Albert Einstein usan la palabra “dios”,
la usan, por supuesto, como una metáfora y un atajo para
referirse a la aquella profunda y misteriosa parte de la Física que aún no entendemos.
“No-teista” serviría para todo esto, pero a diferencia de ateo,
no provoca las mismas reacciones fóbicas e histéricas.
Pero pienso que, realmente, la alternativa
es tomar lo áspero de la misma palabra “ateo”,
precisamente por ser una palabra tabú
que acarrea arrebatos de fobia histérica.
Podria ser más difícil lograr unas masa significativa de adeptos con la palabra ateo
que con la palabra no-teista,
o alguna otra palabra que no sea confrontativa.
Pero si llegaramos a lograrlo con esta temible palabra, ateo,
habría un impacto político más grande.
Ahora, yo diría que, si yo fuera religioso, tendría con mucho temor hacía la evolución. Aún más,
tendría miedo de la ciencia en general si fuera comprendida de forma apropiada.
Y eso es poque el punto de vista cientifico
hacía el mundo es mucho más emocionante, más poético,
más lleno de grandes maravillas que cualquiera
que salga de los pobres arsenales de la imaginación religiosa.
Como Carl Sagan, otro héroe recientemente fallecido, lo puso,
«¿por qué será que es tan dificil que ninguna religion dominante ha visto a la ciencia
y concluído, 'esto es mejor de lo que pensé!'
El universo es más grande de lo que nuestro profeta dijo,
mejor, más sutil, más elegante? En lugar de eso dicen, ¨no, no, no,
mi dios es un dios pequeño y asi quiero que se quede¨.
Una religión, vieja o nueva,
que enfatize la magnificiencia del universo
como es revelada por la ciencia moderna
podría motivar reservas de reverencia y admiración
difícilmente documentadas por los cultos convencionales.
Ahora, esta es una audiencia elitista,
así que esperaría que al menos un 10% de ustedes sean religiosos.
Muchos de ustedes probablemente están subscritos a nuestra educadas creencia cultural de que debemos respetar la religión,
pero también sospecho un buen número de ustedes
secretamente detesta la religión tanto como yo lo hago.
(Risas)
Si eres uno de ellos, y claro que muchos de ustedes tal vez no lo sean,
pero si eres uno de ellos, te estoy pidiendo que dejes de ser tan educado,
maniféstate y dilo, y si por casulidad eres rico,
piensa un poco en las formas en las que puedes marcar la diferencia.
El grupo de poder religioso en este país
es financiado masivamente por fundaciones, y ni hablar de los beneficios en impuestos
por fundaciones tales como el ¨Templeton Fundation¨ y el ¨Discovery Institute¨.
Necesitamos un anti-Templenton que salga adelante.
Si mis libros vendieran tanto como los de Stephen Hawking,
pero en lugar sólo venden tanto como los de Ricahrd Dawkins, yo mismo lo haría.
La gente siempre habla sobre ¨¿como el 11 de septiembre te cambió?¨
Aquí está el como me cambió a mi.
Dejemos de ser tan condenadamente respetuosos.
Muchas Gracias
(Aplausos)